[Musique]
première chose à propos de moi c'est que j'ai 15 ans
si tu parles aux gens aujourd'hui ils
diront encore oh je ne la crois pas
Seto
ils ont compris à l'époque qu'ils
adoptaient un enfant d'Ukraine qui
a une forme rare  du nanisme,
les barnetts avaient déjà une certaine
présence noire parce que Christine
a publié un livre sur
leur fils Jacob qui est autiste et est un
prodige de la physique et dans son livre
Christine écrit sur la façon dont elle a élevé
son fils leur relation étroite comment elle
et sa famille ont surmonté les obstacles
ensemble
italien
dans l'interview il y a une section
où vous pouvez voir Natalia en
arrière-plan un peu en train de manger
avec la famille mes plats préférés
sont les spaghettis tacos et la pizza mes
boissons préférées ma partie préférée je
vais dire c'est Dr Pepper
les barnetts  se sont vraiment présentés
comme des parents aimants qui vous savez qu'ils ont
travaillé très dur pour élever leurs
enfants et leur donner une bonne vie
est
[Musique] [
Musique]
dans l'article Christine Barnett fait
des allégations très choquantes
étrangères
[Musique]
ils ont dit que Natalia s'est comportée dans  certaines
façons choquantes
auraient essayé de poignarder le couple dans
leur sommeil Christine a allégué que
Natalia l'avait poussée sur une
clôture électrique avait versé de l'eau de javel dans son café
des couteaux cachés dans le canapé et elle que Natalia
aurait sauté de voitures en mouvement mais
surtout le plus choquant
l'allégation est que vous savez que Natalia est une
femme d'une vingtaine d'années à l'époque
prétendant être une enfant
étrangère
[Musique] [
Musique]
elle réfute beaucoup des affirmations de Christine,
elle raconte à quel point elle était très heureuse
d'être adoptée dans le Barnett  Famille,
elle a dit que vous savez qu'elle n'est pas adulte
et elle a dit que les affirmations que Christine
avait faites à propos de ses
marques d'âge adulte, comme avoir ses
règles, étaient de faux
résultats
[Musique]
Natalia a expliqué comment elle
avait du mal à vivre dans l'appartement car
elle ne pouvait pas  atteindre certaines choses dans l'
appartement, vous savez que l'appartement n'a pas été
construit pour permettre à une personne
handicapée de bien se déplacer, elle a
dû marcher seule jusqu'à la bibliothèque, a-t-elle
dit et elle a essentiellement dit que
personne ne l'avait aidée quand elle était à la
appartement et les barnetts
l'ont simplement laissée là-bas pour se débrouiller toute seule en
sachant qu'elle ne pouvait pas
[Musique]
ils ont vu Natalia, vous savez, lutter pour
marcher dans la rue après avoir quitté son
appartement et la mère est sortie de la
maison et a commencé à parler à Natalia
étranger c'est
comme si j'enregistrais deux
personnes à la fois moi et ma sœur aussi
Natalia ne mentait pas sur
son âge, les procureurs du comté qui ont
accusé
les barnetts de négligence envers une
personne à charge ont également déclaré que les
tests ADN qu'ils ont effectués confirment qu'une
femme appelée Anna Gaba est la mère de Natalia,
littéralement beaucoup de gens comme moi
le  commander comme juste pas même les gens comme
moi comme n'importe qui ils aiment les enfants se
moquer des autres enfants comme
beaucoup de gens me regardent différemment mais ça
ne me dérange pas parce que c'est comme ça que je suis
c'est comme ça que Dieu m'a fait je ne '  Ça ne me dérange pas
et c'est comme ça que nous devrions tous être
[Musique]
Michael Barnett est
étranger